ja ich bin auch da gemacht hat so einen
komischen italien täglich seiner mutter
ich würde so der liebe leute bevor es
losgeht mit meinem bella italia tag gibt
es auch eine sache zu sagen der wm war
so dumm mich daran zu erinnern dass er
auf gar keinen fall gedeckt werden
möchte und schreibt richtig ab ist ja
während während du bist du bist
selbstverständlich auch getan ich
wünsche euch viel spaß damit und euch
viel spaß mit dem video
bis gleich
jo leute was geht ab und salute nokia
muss sebastian rank julia von colo katze
ihr wisst bescheid heute ist der via der
bella italia tag zu mir durchgedrungen
der kam ursprünglich von patrick es
kommen auch daran erkennen dass die
fragen geistig komplett behindert sind
aber gut ja der kampf von patrick
überbrücken sumpf und warf dann zu max
und architekt frank eger für max dass
ich jetzt hier meine zeit so tadic
mengen muss neben meist noch gerne und
ja - zusammen ein bisschen schiss
wir zocken tolmein will die das jetzt
noch nicht gesehen haben über die kiste
okay so jetzt hab ich mein zeug und
normalos fragen hier auf dem iphone
die lese ich mal ganz locker weg nur
mehrere uno
was ist deine lieblings pizza verzeiht
mir wenn ich nicht so gut italienisch
sprechen kann ich kein spanisch sprechen
würde man das übersetzen
gehst du pisani ferry ah du keine ahnung
alle die spanisch können schreiben die
in die kommentare
wie kann man das übersetzen was ist
deine lieblings pizza auf spanisch ich
sagte pizarro
vielleicht mache ich irgendwann mal ein
eine s bahn attacke oder sowas kenne er
will ihn los was ist deine lieblings
okay ich bin ich noch was bist du ich
bin nach einer stelle ich dann stehen
wir hier oben einfach hin
ja meine lieblings pizza ist nicht
quattro von magie wie bei wow oder
formate über marx sondern pizza tonno
leute dass der schild pizza motto no
escape the pacific dein leben weiter oh
ich hab jetzt keine zeit dafür
ja meinetwegen machen wir das pizza
tonno mit richtig schön viel thunfisch
richtig viel zwiebeln das ist bestes
beste von einem date mit den geilsten zu
mundgeruch aller zeiten habt könnt ihr
alles klären
tester funktioniert nicht
kaputt produziert nicht ja so da sind
work nur funktional ja legal gut deine
komme wieder mit rüber ja pizza tonno
ist der schnitt alter es ist pizza
pommes auch für diejenigen die bisher
pumpen gehen so wie ich hier ganz gut
weil richtig viel eiweiß ja ok damit
sich hardcore definieren will dann sind
die fette des käses doch halt die fed
und die kohlenhydrate von teilchen nicht
sogar arbeite weiß läuft auf jeden fall
weit von fischen deswegen ein bisschen
kennen will nach dem training ist mit
pizza tonno beste meine lieblings pixel
so nummer zwei pizzabrötchen mit oder
ohne der triticale pizzabrötchen wie
willst du die dippen wurde übersinnlich
kräuter kräuterbutter oder so hermann
man gibt doch keine pizzabrötchen
pizzabrötchen sind solche teile ich habe
gerade eben zwei gegessen
vielleicht hole ich denke mal die packen
das video nehmen meist nicht oder doch
das macht macht doch dann machen wir
jetzt einen kurzen cut so leitherer
sommerwetter meine habe stehen um besser
ab nicht sogar hier
diese brötchen einer komplett
unbekannten marke pizza gerd ich
versuchte zu verdecken damit dass mir
keiner produkt entworfen kann habe ich
respekt und die ist man einfach nicht
mit dem vertreter hast du gelernt
deswegen pizzabrötchen natürlich ohne
dick weil mein pc wo ich einfach nicht
gibt wenn man nicht in die hölle kommen
will
magst du männer mit c klar weil wenn man
mit den roma macht dann kann man sich so
richtig schön hier mit dem volvo ich bin
ja geil mario hat ist nur mit
schnurrbart liebs noch ja ich stehe hier
so mitten in dem nichts im prinzip noch
so verkorkst auch gerade raus hier vorne
hier in der mitte auch so einen
komischen teil auszahlen aber ja also
mit schnurrbärten mag ist auf jeden fall
eine homo mario und luigi sind gute
beispiele oder vario oder war luigi für
alle die wie heißt das super smash bros
brawl kennen
für die bi und super mario strikers
charged das fußballspiel schreiben das
jetzt in die kommentare bitte weil aus
diesen beiden spielen kenne ich mario
und in die mangel kenne ich schon viel
länger
aber weil vario war luigi und noch ein
spiel was ich auch ultra geil fand war
mario galaxy alter 12 kanal nicht aus
falls erhalten ist als erste oder so ich
weiß es gar nicht aber das hat mich ja
so geflasht
das war ultra da ich hab so hart gefällt
dieses spiel werde ich richtig
sentimental weil ich denke bevor jetzt
alle anfangen zu heulen machen wir
weiter mit diesem dummen tag hier ja
lieblingsort in italien
das ist bisher tricky ich meine genau
wie max bin ich auch immer im urlaub in
meran mehr an
in alta badia in südtirol im
ironischerweise im norden von italien
cluster ne-yo aber ich würde weiß gar
nicht ob es ist längst da sein würde
miran ich glaube fast venedig venedig
oder florenz weil noch eine gamer faro
von mir
assassin's creed er so geflasht hat
diese einfach das war sogar ich hatte so
was wie assassin's creed vorher noch nie
gesehen
es ist einfach das hat mich so umgehauen
diese atmosphäre diese mittelalterliche
szenerie da in florenz in venedig und
ich war selber auch schon in venedig das
war auch relativ cool ist darauf dass da
ja das übel voll da scheiße in der
kanalisation oben trieb wo die goldig
gefahren sind
schreibt man herrscht der codes weg in
die kommentare
das finde ich ganz geil wir machen
selbstmörderische aktion
und wenn es kaputt geschrieben lieblings
hatten die teilen würde ich fast sagen
ich sag einfach drei lieblingsorte weil
ich hier bin ich dran bin ich nicht
heruntergefallen wurde leicht weil ich
drei mal soviel zweck habe wie max sage
ich meran venedig und florenz so und
dann ist dieser tag auch schon beendet
ich muss jetzt noch weiter tagen und
nichtig den händen der ihr mit mir im
video ist noch linker beschreibung der
muss das machen dann ist muss das machen
und ich würde sagen hier sowie taktik
ich auch mal also sorry falls du das
siehst du musst das auch machen
erst jetzt komme ich eigentlich alles an
leute macht's gut
viel spaß mit den tags von dennis sui
und markus habe ich vergessen habe ich
nicht diese drei und ja dann würde ich
mal sagen macht's gut leute servus